[Music]  dr. show you boys how you do it daddy  higher for the foster babies  try to keep up  you've got breathe wow this place is  amazing why the buns gonna meet us here  he must be held up somewhere hey up here  Astro Boy if you think you can take our  top prize spot your room dead wrong  help me get out of here this summer from  Guillermo del Toro  [Music]  [Applause]  scary stories to tell in the dark this  film is not yet rated some people move  on without us  not us this summer from guillermo del  toro by the next scary stories to tell  in the dark this film is not yet rated  I'd rather rule in Hell than serve in  heaven there are watches all over the  city  destroyed the girl  don't underestimate Who I am battle  angel rated pg-13 they were 14  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you